Hey youtubers it’s Charlie, this is going
to be all about the end of the Star Wars Universe.
At Dark Horse Comics.
After December 31st they are not allowed to
print or sell any new copies of any of their
Star Wars comics.
I’ve also got some Episode 7 news, but holy
shit.
No more Dark Horse Star Wars.
In honor of that Dark Horse is doing this
epic Farewell Digital Bundle.
You can buy every single Star Wars title they
ever printed for $300.
It’s not a going out of business sale or
anything.
As some of you correctly assumed.
Because Disney owns Star Wars and they took
the rights to the comics.
Dark Horse isn’t making new ones.
I flipped a little when I found out that the
Disney deal goes beyond that.
Dark Horse has to stop selling new versions
of their old comics.
In case you don’t read a lot of comics,
it’s just like new printings of old books.
The Lord of the Rings books were originally
published in the 1950s and every couple of
years a new edition is released.
If you’re old enough or a big comics historian
you might remember the original Marvel Star
Wars comics.
After New Hope was released in theaters in
1977, Lucasfilm granted the comic book rights
to Marvel.
It started as a direct adaptation of the movies
but then they branched the stories out.
It ran for 107 issues till 1986.
They had a letters to the editor column in
it called “Star Words”.
That was like right before Jim Shooter came
in.
Marvel went through like 3 editor-in-chiefs
at the time.
Supposedly some of the people that worked
there at the time say that their big franchise
deal with Star Wars saved Marvel from bankruptcy,
because Star Wars was so popular.
1986, the year Marvel printed their last Star
Wars comic, was also the same year Dark Horse
Comics was founded as a company.
They didn’t start publishing Star Wars comics
till 1991.
But Dark Empire was their first storyline.
It was probably the first time I ever thought
about a specific comic book that I really
wanted.
I was just a little kid and I think one of
my friends got Issue Number 1 and it was the
most amazing thing I’d ever seen.
It was right before they re-released the original
trilogy in THX, that was 1995 and the Star
Wars Insider Fan Club became a thing in 1994.
So for most children of the 80s, the Dark
Horse comics were you’re only way to experience
new stories set in the Star Wars universe.
The funny thing is that now it’s more than
20 years later.
The majority of us who were little kids then,
probably have little kids ourselves who are
going to learn about Star Wars from all the
new Disney Marvel stuff.
Dark Empire and Tales of the Jedi were my
favorite storylines from all the Dark Horse
stuff.
But just for fun my TOP 5 titles from worst
to best are
Their First Boba Fett Solo Title, The Mara
Jade Solo Title, Fall of the Sith Empire,
Golden Age of The Sith and Dark Empire.
Just the first Dark Empire.
I didn’t like Dark Empire 2 as much.
You can kind of tell I stopped reading the
Dark Horse stuff after I got too busy with
school.
So all of the stuff they published after the
prequels I have not read.
Let me know what you’re favorite Star Wars
comic is.
And even if you don’t want to buy the $300
special deal you can still buy individual
comics at a 50 percent discount.
I think most of them are half off.
It’s all on Dark Horse’s website.
So
now that we’ve shed a tear for our childhood
let’s talk about Episode 7.
I’m still totally calling it Episode 7.
It just seems more natural.
The newest rumor is that one of the Spinoffs
will be a Suicide Squad team up style movie
about the team that stole the plans for the
original death star.
It would involve Han Solo’s character, Aaron
Paul and Max Von Sydow are supposedly involved
and it would tie in with Episode 8.
The one Rian Johnson is working on.
The movie itself would be a grittier heist
type movie set before the events of Episode
4.
Remember, the plans were stolen, then Vader
chased down Princess Leia because he knew
she was connected with the Rebellion and might
have the plans.
Which she stashed in R2.
That way they’d still be able to use the
character and Harrison Ford would have to
be in
every single movie.
Here’s a big question.
Do you want to see one of the new spinoff
movies take place before or in and around
the original trilogy?
We had the Prequels, but I think the idea
with these new films is to create a very diverse
looking star wars movie universe.
They’ve been picking directors and writers
that are all known for very different types
of movies.
All of them good.
I’m super excited about Episode 7, but really
I’m a much bigger fan of Rian Johnson.
So Episode 8 I think will be much
more interesting.
And just as a point of reference, Marvel is
doing the same thing with it’s films too.
It’s got so many, they’re essentially
giving really good indie filmmakers a chance
to make a big studio film and bring their
creativity to it, and because they’re indie
directors.
They don’t have to pay them Michael Bay,
JJ Abrams level salaries.
There’s also something to be said about
not letting JJ Abrams or the other super-producers
out there have total control over the look
and feel of every major franchise.
Even Joss Whedon is stepping back a bit after
Age of Ultron.
He’ll still be a producer on Marvel films,
but mostly he’ll be in a support role.
Helping them fix story problems and making
sure it all hits the level of quality Marvel
wants
to hit.